hello out there
let me know if you can hear me leave a
comment
i am broadcasting
from somewhere
in the deep
southwest united states
i am
quite
quite uh interested to review this
recent article that i saw published last
week
it's not really a publication it's
really a comment
maybe a
jeremiah
i don't know how else to describe it it
caught me by surprise how much folks
were
intrigued by this i don't know how good
the audio quality is i'm as i said i'm
on vacation
i cannot
it's really a comment
i have access to too much in terms of my
recording quality
but i want to block out as much of the
sound
effects from little screaming kids that
i might hear
um so i want to take this opportunity
to go through this popular article
called the big bang
didn't happen and
i want to address some of the concerns
that i've heard about it from
professional colleagues some outright
just dismissing it calling it utter
nonsense not worthy of uh of contention
but um
but i don't think it's it's entirely as
instructive to just outright dismiss it
and say it's it's completely wrong even
though i'm going to outline 10 reasons
why i do think it's wrong and i want to
do that more as a way to describe
how
to look at scientific popularization and
when media claims are made how do you
know if it's clickbait if you're not a
professional scientist
there's a famous saying it might be carl
sagan who said you know takes
ten times as much
emphasis to
uh to refute
i think he said nonsense or bs um we'll
keep it clean in case any of my kids
come through the room uh but uh
uh it takes ten times as much energy
let's say to refute a claim than to make
a claim and yet they claim uh for such a
wavy
topic as saying the big bang didn't
happen uh really the onus is on the
claimant not on the uh proponents of the
current paradigm doesn't mean the
paradigm is entirely correct i'm gonna
outline some of the things
in the um in the article that i think
you know they're worthy of of uh you
know further investigation perhaps but i
want to take this opportunity as again
my role in this channel and my podcast
is to teach you to think as
scientifically as possible if you're a
scientist or a non-scientist if you're a
graduate student now i kind of think of
this as kind of like office hours and
wanting to
portray it in a way that
anybody can understand
and hopefully
get uh insight into the nature of which
of these claims are worthy of your
attention is this just click bait
in other words so
uh so let's get started i want to share
my screen this is the first of these
live stream i'm going to do another one
pretty soon i'm coming up on uh the goal
i set for this channel
way back when
when i first started was to get to the
most important number in all of science
which is to get
69
420 subscribers
um we're less than 100 away i believe
from that
very important number very significant
number so
um and then i'm going to shut the
channel down uh no i'm not going to do
that uh i really enjoy this this is my
first kind of ama style thing that i've
done in a while i will do a proper ama
in the coming weeks maybe on my birthday
in early september
if and when we do hit 70 000 subscribers
that'll be fun
uh and uh and so i uh hopefully you'll
have an opportunity to ask some
questions and i'll let you know about
that but for now i was alerted to this
by you know someone very very well known
in the media uh but not entirely liked
by everyone on this uh on this channel
who asked me if this is real or should i
take this article the big bang didn't
happen or never happened should i take
that seriously
so i want to
first call up the paper
or the article rather and this is in iai
news which is the institute for art and
ideas there's a link in the video
description below so click on that um
clicking a thumbs up if you're
interested in learning more about this
too just give me some
some encouragement and uh so i'm going
to zoom in on the article let's see if i
can do this um this has there's a new
computer there it is so you guys can all
see that i hope
and i'll scan through the article in
real time so the claim by eric lerner
who is a well-known person even though i
didn't really know much about him he is
the president and chief scientist of lpp
fusion
and he is the author of a very similar
titled book to this article called the
big bang never happened now that was one
of my first kind of uh i would say
warning signs but but sort of a maybe a
red flag that came in
um
and that was you know whether or not we
can really say
uh there's any there's complete lack of
interest in uh you know in a personal
sense uh from this particular individual
so you know i'm not going to speculate
on why or why not he would write this to
you know is it to sell a book is it to
um is it to you know get attention for
something but you always have to ask are
there are there non-scientific
motivations at work um
so um
so we'll take a look through the article
and we'll ask ourselves you know about
the uh the
underlying
claims and if they have merit and i
think that's that's the uh sense i have
about 15 20 minutes before i have to go
take care of a kid um who may or may not
pop through the door in any moment so
i'll
move the door camera away
um and i'm a little bit under the
weather so i hope you guys appreciate
this i do want you to say so
uh stay tuned on sunday i'm putting out
a feature length video a 30 minute video
part of the 30 minute thesis
um conversation
that describes how
the universe's formation of the lightest
elements the hydrogen in this water was
formed and that's part of big bang
nuclear synthesis which is one of the
three major pillars that makes us
believe with great insight into the big
bang's veracity and even the author eric
claims that that is true that the
formation of the elements although he
disputes the the totality of the
elements he says that actually only one
element in particular and actually it's
an isotope of
hydrogen he claims to be evidence for
the big bang um but everything else is
dismissed by him
and that's an isotope of hydrogen called
deuterium i also have a video coming up
about deuterium and why it's so
important in a video that i'm calling in
the most expensive water in the universe
okay so let's look at this article
um again this isn't i just did a recent
event for them where i described the uh
i described the uh well i was a host and
moderator between carlo revelli eric
weinstein and sabine hassenfelder
with a discussion of uh the reality of
quantum mechanics so i'm affiliated with
the institute for arts and ideas and
they've invited me to speak they
actually invited me to speak in
september where eric is going to be
at uh their festival of arts and ideas
or how the lights gets in festival i
couldn't make it oh yeah see there it is
eric lerner will be speaker at our
upcoming festival how the light gets in
london 2022 i was invited i can't make
it
um teaching and so forth so uh i'll miss
out on that but one of my friends priya
naratagen professor yale she is
apparently going to be debating him so
if you're in england if you're in the uk
make sure to check it out um
so uh the iai is a well-known um uh
you know
as a well-known project i suppose to um
to bring science and artistic ideas to
the to the general public
and so i like them i support i don't
know i don't work for them i don't get
anything from them um except uh you know
the intellectual satisfaction of uh
debating with uh friends like carlo and
sabine and eric anyway okay so everyone
who sees the james webb telescope
uh space telescope image of the cosmos
are beautifully on spartan okay that's
true um and that's not at all predicted
by theory okay so there's the first
thing so what they're showing is that
all these images in cosmology they're
extremely surprising they're not at all
expected lots of surprises and not
necessarily pleasant ones
one paper's title
begins with
candid title
of
um
uh begins with
the title panic okay candid explanation
so let's see what does that what is he
talking about there so i mean panic that
must be in the big bang's totally uh
farcical right so let's let's uh let's
investigate let's click on this link and
see what does it bring up
panic at the discs
first rest frame optical observations of
galaxy structure at z greater than three
which aws t in the smacks field
this is actually by written by the third
author is a former guest on the podcast
christopher consli's professor in the uk
obviously this is not saying panic you
know
that the big bang theory is wrong as
this guy starts off eric starts off his
article as if to you know bring
some doubt and dispute and cosmologists
are in a state of panic no they're not
in a state of panic uh this is a joke a
tongue-in-cheek article and i would be
surprised if this actually gets uh
published with the title panic
it's obviously a reference a call back
to the
well-known uh popular music band the
panic at the disco so they're just being
cute i think it's kind of funny and um i
don't think there's anything wrong with
starting a paper like this now what's
surprising is that christopher consoles
is the editor of app j
or one of the editors of appj and he may
um
he may actually have a
uh you know
a say an override in this paper's title
actually getting public okay so let's
just take it for granted that this book
this paper is not about saying that
people should panic they're talking
about the surprising result that
greater than 1.5 disc galaxies dominate
over the over all fraction of
morphologies with a factor of 10 higher
number destined seen by the hubble space
telescope at these redshifts now why
would that be a crisis why would that
why should that be a problem
well according to eric the big bang
didn't happen so the universe is much
much older and in the big bang model the
universe is only uh 13.7 billion years
old therefore it shouldn't have enough
time to spin up these galaxies into
uh the configurations that they're known
as spinning galaxies or disc galaxies
now that could be because the previous
telescope hubble was not designed to
even have the capability to see galaxies
at these high redshift so actually i
think that there's a lot of um you know
there's a lot of i don't say honesty or
integrity but but the point is is that
the hubble space telescope was not
capable of seeing galaxies at these high
redshifts so it's not so surprising that
when you have a new tool like this
you're going to see things that your
other telescope wouldn't have seen
imagine if you know hubble using the
mount wilson 100 inch telescope in los
angeles had said uh well you know i see
so many galaxies and they're so far away
from us um and then when the palomar
observatory in san diego county was uh
opened up 200 inches it has four times
the collecting area you can see things
four times fainter or even more uh and
it's oh well it's inconsistent with what
uh with what hubble saw in mount wilson
well of course it is because it has more
capability so it's going to have a more
finer um toothed comb to filter out
things that hubble couldn't see there's
another issue in that he doesn't address
but any proper scientists should address
this that the calibration of the of the
james webb telescope is actually a pro a
work in progress it's not that we have
uh you know ultimate confidence in the
calibration of it
um and now we talk about uh they're
blatantly contradicting the hypothesis
of the big bang so um so that now he
also goes in on switchback screens now
back to the uh paper review so that's
the first thing so he's he's trying to
so doubt in the in the reader's mind and
of course this gets spun up in the press
oh man astronomers in chaos in a panic
uh they're everything that we thought is
wrong uh of course it's going to get
headlines and and he knows this and and
uh and it's a little disappointing that
that um you know so much is being made
in the popular press
um and you know this when you know your
grandmother or your grandfather starts
asking you about these things oh the big
bang didn't happen
um
so um now these galaxies what he shows
they're jw fc galaxies so the same size
galaxies near to us now there's nothing
quantitative about that and actually
it's known that in a expanding universe
there will be a minimum size of galaxies
so galaxies can be no smaller than a
certain size and that's called the
angular diameter distance i have a video
about that someday
coming out but but the bottom line is
that we don't have any reason to suspect
that galaxies should be smaller or
bigger than a given size which is a
constant size about an arc minute or so
and
um and he's saying that it's not at all
consistent with what's expected of this
now red shifts up to five et cetera and
there was a lot made in the very first
couple of days where these data are
picked from
uh and that was uh that was saying that
galaxies were made at redshifts of 10
and 20 much much higher redshift and
some of those have been retracted
and there is an a normal rush to get
data out and to get analyzed to be the
first to make a claim about the
existence of galaxies at extremely high
redshift which equates to extremely
young ages and of course what eric
lerner is dr lerner is trying to do here
is to criticize the big bang for not
having enough capacity or enough age to
both um create galaxies have galaxy
formation and also have galaxies to
start spinning up and have galactic
rotation so you know those are
legitimate criticisms and yet we have to
first make sure that the uh that the
calibration between redshift and
distance is calibrated and of course in
his model what he's doing is doing
something that i actually have a
connection to
um and that is via um one of my
colleagues two of my colleagues at ucsd
so what he starts with was tiny and
smooth galaxies mean no expansion and
thus no big bang so he's claiming his
model which is a form of plasma
cosmology we'll get into that in just a
second
that plasma cosmology accounts for how
this the universe uh is actually
structured in a plasma model such as his
uh there is no expansion and therefore
there's no big bang the big bang is the
inevitable consequence of a universe
that's expanding in that if you trace
the clock backwards you get a universe
as much smaller denser hotter than in
his current phase
so he's trying to cast down on it this
is what he's trying to do
and that's all fine uh but he has an
agenda obviously he has an agenda that
he wants to promulgate his cosmological
model and there's a danger that you'll
account anything um
as evidence for your theory and
everything is evidence against another
theory
um
so
uh
so he's gone on about this merger
process uh and how this has has actually
not been successful i should also point
out some of the features of uh of his
cosmology which have not changed so this
is point number three i think of my ten
uh so the first one is that
uh that the
you know the state the big bang never
happened and then claim things anything
like panic in the title is really
evidence that uh cosmology is in crisis
because of the title of a paper i think
that's kind of species to be honest
um it's it's kind of tongue-in-cheek
maybe he's not super serious about it
who knows um number two calibration uh
has not been applied number three he's
got an agenda a model um so his his
colleagues um uh
and uh and and he are trying to uh uh
trying to postulate that you don't need
to have a big bang to have the
structures that we've seen in the
universe since uh the these data have
come out now what's interesting is that
his model his model came out in 1991
and that was before even the kobe
satellite data had been released showing
that there were fluctuations in what he
calls the alleged or supposed cosmic
microwave background let me see if i can
find what he calls it um
uh asymmetries in the micro background
that should not exist
let's see here
that drive cosmic evolution micro
background phenomena that we observed
okay so we're going to get into this
topic in just a bit
can be explained
using laboratory
okay in other in other uh
works he's dismissed the cosmic
microwave background and completely
saying it is not based on it's not uh to
be counted as evidence for the uh hot
dense early phase of the big bank
so he says and something could have
existed before the big bang i mean
nobody's claiming that existed in the
big bang model although there are models
as we talked about a month ago with
anaheigis the bouncing cosmology there
are
structures and structure formation iso
curvature fluctuations things like that
that can take place
in so-called bouncing or cyclic models
he's dismissing those completely
he doesn't believe in a cyclic model
okay so just as there's the big bang if
the big bang
hypothesis were valid theory should
expect that jwc looked farther on space
back in time there should be fewer and
fewer about galaxies and eventually none
a dark age in the cosmos well okay so
there is a dark age in the cosmos and
it's before the earliest galaxies that
are shown in the jwst data
uh so
so there are blind spots in the cosmic
um in the cosmic web in fact what he
dismisses completely as the result of
what's called a cosmic screening we'll
talk about that in just a bit
um
uh that cosmic microwave background is a
dark there are no galaxies when the cmb
is produced at 380 000 or 370 000 years
after the big bang he can't explain that
so um so there are actual blank spots in
the cosmic structure formation history
now he's saying while big bang theorists
were shocked and panicked by these so
again he's he's equating like all these
all these theories by the way the papers
that were published
um with that title or i was submitted
it's not published and i think it's it's
very you have to be very careful if
you're a good scientist i'm saying this
to my students and to people that want
to know how to assess
both publicly disseminated information
and actual scientific data you have to
be very careful with what you quote what
you accuse people of believing and you
have to be extremely careful of what you
how you account and what you're
considering people to be so first of all
the paper that's published a panic
those are not theorists they are not
theorists they are observers so not
getting not understanding who you're
talking to and what the data and what
they're representing it's as egregious
as you know going into an apple store
and getting asking for a samsung phone
it demonstrates a lack of professional
courtesy let me just say and we'll see
later that eric dr lerner
he is uh no stranger to making
accusations against the scientific
community which is another one of my
warning signs the 10 warning signs
so um so they're saying they're shocked
and panicked nobody has been panicked
about these new results
again he is creating a false narrative
that people are a crisis and that um
luckily we have his model which by the
way has been around um since many of you
before many of you were born that are
watching
certainly any of my students that are
watching um 1991 so it's a 31 year old
uh paper a book that he has been
continually harping on and that book was
written before the uh discovery seven
years before the discovery of dark
energy a year before the kobe results
were announced and yet as new data have
come in there's been absolutely no new
progress in this model it's just the
same model that's been recycled since
the time of a man by the name of alfane
and so we'll talk about that let's go
down here so um
so what he talks about here is cosmology
and crisis you see all these different
references etc until the past three
years if a research could self-fund
cosmology research as a silent as in the
case with me
they could still publish heretical
papers so this brings me to a fifth or
sixth point that i i always like to make
a point you should never accuse
scientists of being
a cabal of acting
and that there's a censorship going on i
joke with my students never compare
yourself to einstein and never compare
yourself to giodarno bruno who of course
was burned at the stake for his truly
heretical ideas um at the heretical to
the catholic church in the year 1600 he
was burned at the at the stake
um
now why shouldn't you do that well i
think a lot of times you try to conflate
your ideas with the ideas of people that
were persecuted i often get arguments
like this male to me professor keating
i have this new idea for cosmological
model everybody's wrong um i know you
might think i'm crazy they thought
einstein was crazy
but look what happened with him uh so if
you help me the implication goes then i
will help you and we'll split the nobel
prize um and uh so the op the the
conflation is always between someone
great or someone who is persecuted for
heretical ideas it's very loaded
terminology it's not proper scientific
terminology and it's hard to take it
seriously
i wouldn't take him super seriously at
this point
um other than the fact that uh you know
he he has every right to make legitimate
claims and concerns against the big bang
but he's clearly advocating a position a
position that he has held unwaveringly
since 1991 despite all the new evidence
that's come out for the cosmological
model despite dozens or half a dozen
nobel prizes that have gone to what's
called the standard model of cosmology
namely that the universe it has been
expanding for over 13.7 billion years
and it's predicated on three pillars of
uh that need to be explained
uh in his model or any other alternative
and i did a wonderful episode with my
friend garrett lewis and luke barnes
about two years ago now called the
cosmic revolutionaries handbook and such
a
and such a treatment says that if you
have a revolutionary new idea here's the
list of things you have to overcome in
other words you have to explain
everything that's explained currently
and more you have to make new
predictions otherwise you're just adding
on epicycles so the question is does his
model explain more than the so-called
standard model the standard model of
cosmology features a big bang features
dark matter and dark energy do we know
what those are nope we don't know what
those are we didn't know what 90 of the
periodic table was until the last 80
years so i don't think that's a you know
a true criticism um it doesn't mean that
we'll never know it now if we if we
never have any insight and we just get
stuck in a rut and just keep looking for
the same exact thing yeah you could
criticize it he doesn't believe in dark
matter he doesn't believe that the
universe is expanding let alone that the
expansion is accelerating
for which we have copious evidence he
doesn't believe this cosmic microwave
background is cosmic he doesn't believe
in the redshift of galaxies
and he doesn't believe that the um that
the most of the lightest elements in the
periodic table were formed during a hot
dense phase of the universe because
there was no hot dead space of the
universe so he has to form those in very
exotic uh scenarios
and uh he's been doing this as i said
for so long now almost over three
decades
that uh that some people have actually
criticized it and we can look at the
errors in this this is a wonderful um
website that you should always look at
run by my friend and professor colleague
at ucla
and his name is ned wright
and ned wright
has a whole you know web page dedicated
to this and it's called errors in the
big bang never happened
and so he first goes through the
criticisms of the big bang errors and
alternatives to the big bang and then
miscellaneous earth
so back then i think this i forget when
this uh critic this paper came this this
website rather came out let's see let me
scan down to number so this hasn't been
modified since 2003 um and a lot has
happened since 2003 including the nobel
prize for the discovery of dark energy
uh by past guest brian schmidt and adam
reese you should look for episodes by
them on this channel
um so even back this time there was
enough to dispute in this work this
proposal by learner so now we're
criticizing the critique the alternative
model it's one thing to criticize a
model it's another thing to come up with
another model that doesn't do as good a
job as the model you're disputing so um
and and oftentimes one of the signs that
you're dealing with somebody whose
motives
may not be aligned with what you are uh
looking for
which is the ultimate scientific truth
is that they not only prove somebody
else wrong but they also want to prove
themselves right and it's very difficult
to do uh both either one of those let
alone both of those so um so he goes
through and even back then he was
talking about how hard it was to make uh
clusters of galaxies at large uh at
large times so he's still saying that in
this iai paper right so he's saying to
give an example 150 million light year
sheet of galaxies uh this is in his book
so he's talking about super clusters and
how could super clusters form this is in
2003 ned wright is dismissing the 1991
book by learner of almost the same name
structures take too long to grow
learning valuable a thousand kilometers
a second and 75 million light years h
naught which is the expansion rate of
the universe today we find perfect
agreement as long as omega which is the
crit which is the energy density of the
universe is close to one now in
2003 when ned wright was writing this we
had already measured that omega was
close to one but in 1991 we hadn't we
didn't know if the universe was open or
closed if it had greater than or
negative uh less than uh the critical
density which is what omega equals one
means
and we didn't know the hubble constant
to better than you know ten percent or
twenty percent uncertainty now we know
it to two or three percent uncertainty
and as you'll see that's a critical
ingredient and so he hasn't updated his
same argument in other words he's
recycling the same argument there's not
enough time to grow um even though in
the time that he's written in the book
30 years later we've refined the values
of the input parameters of the big bang
model that he's claiming are wrong
now he also talks about the the spectral
behavior of the um of the big bang uh as
measured by the um by the kobe satellite
and uh others uh as well and because of
that he um
he has uh critique about not only the
existence of the cosmic ray background
but of its fluctuations as well
oh wait
so i had an interloper
graduate student came to bother me um
so i got to wrap up in a few minutes
because the graduate students are
restless um
so uh i do want to go through a couple
more of the highlights okay
um so he claims again uh we
we uh he actually references his model
this is a form of plasma cosmology that
was first popularized by a professor at
uc san diego where i am
his name was
alvain
he won the nobel prize and that's often
used as a
as a way to bolster the
he wanted for plasma physics and he
claimed that plasma pervaded the cosmos
and that there was no big bang now why
did alfane want to show there was no big
bang
al fame wanted to show there was no big
bang because he believed that that was
used as evidence by creationists to
support the biblical narrative of the
genesis event so that wasn't a pure
purely motivated theory by alvin
uh he had ideas and and and
that was 50 years ago
and so now we have um we have eric
lerner dr eric lerner recycling this
model although according to ned wright
ned wright says that he abandoned the
plasma cosmology in the response that he
had to
uh uh to uh what what what ned wright
had put out so in other words lerner
said in a response to ned wright he said
i disavow this uh this model
he says uh ned ryan i'm just reading i'm
not gonna switch back to the website
remarkably learner now disowns the alvin
klein model which plays such a big part
in his book and wants me to give the
proper attribution he points out that he
listed now but but now in the iai paper
he's citing
the uh the alphane paper okay so he's
talking about nobel prize winner al
fayne uh so which is it do you disown it
do you do you not disown it um disavow
it rather and uh so i find this very
very uh
i don't want to say misleading but it
certainly uh kind of playing a
distraction okay so there it is these
scientific equations matter here and now
for decades scientists starting with
physics nobel laureate hans alvin
have shown that the big bang hypothesis
is thrown out the evolution of the
cosmos that we observed today like the
cnb can explain these in physical
processes observing the laboratory well
wouldn't that be great except that if
the universe is not expanding he cannot
explain how the cmb exists at high
redshifts we observe the cmb this is the
most damning evidence i think about and
it didn't exist maybe as as highly
accurately as it does now uh and the
time that ned wright wrote his um or his
dismissal and this proof of the learner
model
but instead he uh he he did not know and
he does not cite the fact that if you
measure the cosmic temperature
of the microwave background it changes
as a function of redshift and we
measured that in different galaxies how
can you possibly explain that in a
universe that's not expanding he has no
answer for that in fact he's dismissive
of the cmb he believes it's due to like
some scattering effects which have been
disproven for decades and again i am not
you know averse to tackling and to
engaging with people who have
alternative ideas don't forget i'm
probably the only person who's ever
interviewed giant narlikar who was
hoyle's best graduate student probably
arguably
fred hoyle was the biggest proponent and
opponent of the big bang he gave the
name big bang to the big bang model as
an insult to the big bang because he
thought it was so preposterous and
allegedly it's a it's a british you know
euphemism for orgasm or something
and so he wanted to humiliate people
that believed in explosive or because
hoyle also was against the creation
genesis 1 1 narrative
and hoyle and nyla carr work very
closely together and they worked
together with jeffrey burbidge and
margaret burbidge and i
sit in jeffrey burbridge's office at uc
san diego so i've interviewed jeffrey
many times before he passed away 12
years ago
we chatted many times about cosmology he
went to his grave believing the big bang
never happened and so-called squashy
steady state cosmology which has been
utterly disproven as i talk about in my
book losing the nobel prize
my first book um but i interviewed giant
marilyn carr i love talking to him uh
and uh and i think you can learn a lot
from people even if you disagree with
them violently about their particular
ideas but why are they doing this what
is this about why are they trying to do
this and that's my goal i want to teach
you to look at these things so the last
thing i want to talk about besides sorry
i talked about you know how does he
explain uh the cmd he doesn't there's
another thing that he can't explain in a
universe that has
no expansion
and everything is moving gravitationally
why do we see some galaxies getting blue
shifted why are they getting
gravitationally attracted to us what how
does he explain general relativity where
if you have any mass density the
universe cannot be static it cannot be
unevolving he doesn't have a good
explanation so he has to come up with
all these epic cycles in his model and
it's not the first time this has ever
happened it's the first time because of
the rise of twitter and the internet
that i'll get emails and messages from
all over the world
asking about this how does he explain
that has he explained the evolution of
the redshift dependence of the cmb in a
universe that's not expanding how does
he explain the changing hubble constant
due to
the presumed evolution
of the universe during expansion how
does he explain that the uh that the
existence of dark energy which we
measure not only from supernovae but we
measure from the cmb alone
um and that is uh left unexplained the
last thing i want to conclude with is
something you always need to do and you
need to look and again consider the
source what is their motivation why are
they writing this
um and so
i just want to conclude with this i'll
look through a couple questions and then
i have to leave okay so the plot process
of plasma filamentation now we're
getting to the good stuff this is
probably the last thing
to use fusion energy the power that
drives the universe and gives light to
the sun this is great and it starts we
need to develop and drive that cosmic
evolution
just as the wright brothers develop the
airplane by studying how birds control
their flight i don't know that that's
exactly how they did it i think leonardo
da vinci looked at birds controlling
their flight
so today we can only control ultra
plasma where fusion reactions occur by
studying how plasmas behave at all
scales in the cosmos we need to imitate
nature not try to fight it
we at lpp fusion have been applying that
knowledge concretely
so now now talk now he starts getting
into funding of these processes the
scale of the sun work on larger scale
has been hobbled by the straitjacket of
the big bang hypothesis which has
diverted hundreds of thousands of
talented research into feudal
calculations of imaginary entities like
dark matter dark energy that have
invented to prop up a failing theory
so cosmology can emerge as christians
establish that recognize that the big
bang never happened so
if you click on this link now you come
to where he's published his papers
and
when he talks about he's published these
papers and so forth they only appear on
his website
they're not published in journal now
he's saying there's censorship now to
censor an article
is an incredibly difficult thing uh you
have to have uh multiple referees that
would agree and collaborate and collude
to uh to and i like the website by the
way if eric if you're watching
congratulations on this website it's
really cool animation take it from me
i don't know anything about your fusion
processes but i dislike the kind of
conflation again
of the universe
and the incorrectness of the big bang
theory with now we need more funding for
the type of fusion research that i'm
doing uh i think that's smacks of a
conflict of interest personally
and while it might be noble and there
might be in other words you might be
able to say well people are are not
funding my cosmic researches and they're
not funding my fusion research therefore
you know i'm being censored and
ostracized at the highest levels to get
ostracized from from journal articles
almost impossible um he's he's talking
about and not being allowed to publish
uh i think that that's those are kind of
very bold statements he has published uh
before
um in in some journal articles as he
mentioned
i don't think that there's um you know
much point now i look through the
articles there's 60 pages long
and that brings me to the final point
again uh quoting
from uh quoting from uh carl sagan i
think or i don't even know who it was
from but it takes 10 times as much
energy to refute
i don't want to say any bad words okay
guys uh you fill in fill in you know the
blank here to refute bs
uh that it does to produce i'm not
calling him bs i think he's probably
very knowledgeable about so this is what
i find often that people are like so
down the rabbit hole they haven't really
collaborated they haven't been involved
in university settings uh they're
they're trying to come out of left field
using this argument that you know worked
for einstein they'll work for me
um and so i wanted to just you know
alert you when you see articles like
this go through the links take them
seriously take eric take people like him
seriously he will be debating you know
one of the foremost cosmologists in the
world priyank rajan at uh at have a
light gets in festival i hope that'll be
great i hope they'll get a a good
turnout
um and uh maybe she can you know even
substantiate more with what i am talking
about for her expertise in black holes
and formation of those objects and how
they anchor and
behave in time of galaxies
he also as some people are mentioning
gregory head and others are mentioning
things like um he he also dismisses the
abundance of light elements
and because of that uh that would be a
reason to dismiss this
well i don't think that's exactly true
at all in fact i have a video as i said
on sunday you can find a link to it on
the channel already for the premiere so
watch that video that's about how do we
know the abundances of all the lightest
elements on the periodic table not just
the helium and deuterium that he's
talking about so how do we know that the
universe originated from a hot dense
state one of the biggest most precise
ways we have of doing that is measuring
the abundance of light elements and i'm
going to be
presenting
as i did in my cosmology for
undergraduates advanced undergraduates
classes it's an advanced lecture that
you don't you know i put in a lot of
entertaining jokes and my editor's
really fun um and so i think you'll like
it even if you're not an expert but i go
through the equations and the
calculations of how we know the
abundance of uh and calculate the
abundance that can only take place if
the universe was once as hot as the
hottest plasma fusion reactors that eric
lerner or his colleagues could ever
consider
and that's uh tens of millions of
degrees kelvin and that does not exist
in the plasma cosmology
universe and in fact he has to come up
with other ways to form it which the
article by ned wright which i'll put a
link to in the show notes when we get
some time um
disputes as well he talks about another
way to produce lithium and other of the
light elements that i talk about in the
video on sunday so make sure you uh do
click and decide um so i see a lot of
like you know questions in the uh in the
chat i don't have too much time
uh let's see if they're uh let's see
could the james webb simon here i'll add
that uh could the james webb space
telescope could prove that there was no
big bang no the jameson space telescope
is not designed really to do
uh proof of the big bang that's what i'm
studying i'm sending the microwave
background which is the oldest light in
the universe these are the oldest
galaxies in the universe and it's a much
higher redshift than hubble could ever
see so what do they may mean for the age
of the universe after we start out the
age of the contra it doesn't change the
age of the universe at all the age of
the universe is primarily determined by
its composition
and uh the hubble constant and we know
those exquisitely well there is tension
between two different values they can
differ by at most nine or ten percent
which could differ change the age of the
universe by a billion years but it
doesn't change it by infinite number of
years
um
and so uh yeah michael i don't know i
could interview him i have a lot of
other things on my plate right um and uh
i think this is pretty good he's
debating uh priya and i think that uh
hopefully they'll make that available
for people to see as well
and that's next month or if you're in
england go there um
and check it out uh brad s um you're
welcome uh that's great uh tr uh paper
trolls yeah i don't know i mean i i
don't consider him a troll i think he's
earnest i think he's uh you know he's
trying to do the right thing i don't
think he's doing anything you know
scientifically untoward i just think he
has you know perhaps confirmation bias
where he's trying to um uh where he's
trying to
um you know really motivate his model
and take down the predominant one now
it's true that we don't know what dark
energy rob and dark matter is that
doesn't mean we don't know you know we
we didn't know what quarks were until
the 1980s and 90s really uh it doesn't
mean that they didn't exist or weren't
real in some sense okay uh seriously why
uh
i don't know what's going on here super
sticker uh sheba dog okay good thank you
tim
uh so what if he's wrong but we need to
reevaluate we do have to reevaluate the
universe's age that is true we have to
constantly evaluate it and the thing is
is that if if i thought you know like a
quasi-steady state model was right
then there'd be an infinite age
effectively of the universe and we are
investigating that with things like
looking to disprove or really that's
what we do as scientists we don't look
to prove models we look to disprove them
anyway i gotta run it's my last couple
days of vacation
uh had a great time with you guys and uh
yeah we'll do this again remember to you
know try to share the channel uh so i
can grow that magical number 69 420
subscribers we'll do it we'll do a um
we'll do a uh a q a maybe we'll do it
live and you guys can ask me all sorts
of crazy questions and fun questions i'd
love to answer them and uh and for now
yeah i'm enjoying uh enjoying the time
don't forget sunday i do a deep dive i
don't ever dumb things down guys don't
ever ask me to dump something down so
you know you guys are i know some of you
are truck drivers and whatever i love
you guys that's so much fun to talk to
you guys i think all scientists have to
do this we get paid to do it except on
vacation come on i gotta have a little
vacation uh but the point is we get paid
by you guys we owe you guys stuff and
i'm doing it i'm not gonna dumb it down
you're gonna enjoy the video on sunday
make sure you uh set the notification
about bye everybody had a fun and i'll
talk to you guys soon
you